if people want to see how the over
racialization of everything really
degrades society and crushes people's
thinking this is a story that I saw last
week and I really wanted to hit on with
you guys there was a young girl by the
name of Jen Angel who was murdered by a
black man and she was a lefty and a
social justice Warrior and everything
else and that's what her friends are and
now her friends are lobbying to free the
man that murdered her it's unbelievably
extraordinary take a look at this clip a
reverse was Angel's friend she's one of
several people calling on local
authorities to pursue an alternative to
traditional prosecution I know Jen
believed that
we need to address harm and create
accountability that is that is really
rooted in in
looking at the root causes of why harm
happens burst says Angel strongly
disagreed with the current criminal
justice system and would not want her
alleged killer to go to prison like
locking somebody in a cage is that
really gonna bring Jen back instead
burst says Angel would have liked a form
of restorative justice to happen friends
of angels have been working alongside
the non-profit restore Oakland and
restorative justice is really about
healing and Healing Begins with telling
the truth and our current Criminal
Justice System robs any opportunity of
truth-telling from all parties
just to be clear it was the it was the
murderer who was 19 years old I think
she was in the in her 30s but uh Peter
this story like this they have a dead
friend
and their concern is that the the
perpetrator of this murder somehow not
be treated poorly basically should just
walk out there like is this not just the
perfect
um end game of all of this nonsense all
right well two points on this type one
is that this is proof further proof that
progressivism is a mental disorder
number two I think it's what you call
um pathological altruism when you have
when you have so much good intention
that it goes beyond the realm of what's
beneficial and becomes negative you know
and this seems to be a recurring theme
with the left we saw it only recently
when they were talking about abortion
they wanted so much tolerance that it
became a bad thing yes tolerance is good
of course it's good but there is such a
thing as too much tolerance and finding
that distinction is a fine political art
and for some reason liberals don't seem
to be able to do it and here we are with
this you know they're saying oh no you
know this this poor man he shouldn't be
held accountable for his actions well of
course he should because he's committed
a crime and you know there is there is a
rule of law in America and these are the
very same people who when George Floyd
was killed were calling for his killer
to be arrested and tried and potentially
killed so not only are they diluted but
they also have inconsistent principles
it's like I want to get all liberals
together in a conference room get them
to decide on what the principles are
come out and debrief the rest of the
world on it because then we can actually
move forward with the conversation but I
mean this really is a case of
pathological altruism and it's almost
exclusive to the left yeah Douglas
Jordan Peterson talks about this a lot
you've written about it that you know
basically if in your hierarchy of values
you put tolerance at the top you
actually become the most intolerant
person what would you say to someone
like if you were sitting in a room with
a friend trying to explain to her why
perhaps this is not the best way uh to
get Justice for her friend or to solve
any of these problems how do we
deprogram some of these people or do we
just have to let a certain segment of
the society go well the first thing is
that she also didn't care about her
friend very much
um just obviously not she cares about
her own narcissistic self-presentation
more than she does about her her friend
as murder the second thing is she's
obviously uh the the friends of the the
poor and clearly don't understand the
most basic point of Justice or indeed
the criminal justice system the criminal
justice system is not in place in order
to heal
it is not in place in order to provide
some Cosmic social justice the primary
purpose of imprisonment imprisonment is
punishment is punishment for crime
foreign